Destiny and Zip Zip just Destiny's not Destiny's not a forensic
expert. And we're going to go over Zip Zip. Zip Zip is some dumb
[__] on the internet sucking Destiny's Yep.
Holy holy disavow, okay? Disavow disavow disavow disavow. >> Oh,
I totally I totally disavow language, but I agree with the sentiment
100%. what they have to say. They got the position. Oh my god.
Rose has been served with to be deposed. Uh yes, in addition
to all the attention that I'm sure that she is getting and in
addition to all the Kiwi Farms users trying to like stalk her
in order to gain her hand in marriage, I bet, right? This is
uh She Food Chops is talking about Rose here, I believe.
Um I don't I don't understand where this ban fit comes from.
Very very odd. Rose, I we're trying to comment on appearances
here. Because they they love the idea of a supple 19-year-old
to marry, okay? Um Uh-huh. Like like the thing is is that like
what Why is it like like I'm sure she would love the idea of
being served a subpoena by Pixie,
champion of women, by the way, I'm sure, after being predated
Uh champion of women, by the She'd love to be served a subpoena
by Pixie,
champion of women, by the way. I just the the subpoena thing
is like, okay, this person has information relevant to
this case.
I I don't think you have to consider or concern yourself with
like how
much they want the subpoena, right?
Is the best sweeper DG could prop up? Um this is the most shameless
one, probably. I'm guessing most shameless
of being served a subpoena by Pixie,
champion of women, by the way, I'm sure, after being predated
on possibly by a like predator. Great stuff. Amazing.
Uh which predator is that? Is that That's Destiny or
So, Rose loves being served a subpoena after being predated on
by a predator.
I I'll I'll play that for you again. Why is it like like I'm
sure she would love the idea. Like this person is literally just
struggling to form words. There's no consistent like stream of
consciousness going on in their brain at all. They're just struggling
to put words together to continue to have the stream go on.
of being served a subpoena by Pixie,
champion of women, by the way, I'm sure, after being predated
on possibly by a like predator. Great stuff. Amazing.
They got the position.
I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure there's just a lot of clips like this
of her watching my vod having essentially no commentary or internal
Amazing stuff, though.
Amazing stuff. Why she being so unhinged? I don't know. I don't
know, man. Some goofy stuff, okay?
All right. So, there's a couple different things. There's just
two I think two quick things I was going to go through was um
the Hassan
the Hassan vod, okay? Hassan decided he's going to go over the
sick tweet today, talk about this whole thing a little bit, okay?
Let's check it out. the court?
Within the next year, Food Chops is going to put out a Twitlonger
Substack, whatever it's called, about how she's a victim
of Destiny, too.
Uh but very likely. Yeah, very likely. >> losing his all
of his income and being outed publicly versus a minor in the
middle of a legal battle he appears to be losing. What are you
talking about? This is like
Wait. Oh, is this new?
Destiny's not having a meltdown in DG chat because spoiled white
girl Pixie Love committed the crime of hiring an expert forensics
guy to verify that Bonnell really had been tampering with and
falsifying evidence submitted to the court. Wait, what the [__]
is this?
Dude, I'm going to lose it. It cannot be this meme for court
[__] Plaintiff has preceded 3,000 documents or produced
3,000 documents this [__] piece of [__]
sent me. Every single Discord message in a separate text file.
And like 80% of what she provided were just messages from our
group chat. I'm so [__] annoyed.
Like this whole thing is a giant [__] joke to her.
By the way, I'm pretty sure Pixie did that to have like all of
the, you know, forensics like things like to have every single
message have a timestamp, probably kind of important.
And listen, Destiny's learned all this stuff. He's he's learned
how to make chat GPT coalesce files together. Why not just apply
that? Does he have no understanding of abstraction whatsoever?
He already did it. He already figured out how to join files together,
put them in the same thing, the same spreadsheet,
Why does he just apply that again? Her it's all memes and
a source they paid some super [__] experts forensics
guy to say my logs were tampered with and they're comparing them
to Solo's logs who we can't depose, who isn't part of the case.
How can Don't worry, Matt. We'll cover it. >> speak for
any of this [__] I'm actually so [__]
It's actually so [__] [__] Destiny that
50K is going a long way compared to whatever you spent. She's
not using that 50K. Her parents are loaded and are covering this
100%.
It's so annoying that I've spent so many days and weeks of my
time Oh, see, now
the sick
compiling stuff she hasn't turned over anything and just frolicking
around like nothing Oh, I If this [__] Pixie over,
if she can't like raise money for her lawsuit cuz now Hassan
thinks she's
Bro, she's not rich. All right. I don't know. She's I don't think
her parents are rich from what I understand, but
you know, I I don't really know for sure, but I don't think so.
>> thing is even happening and they're just playing games
the whole [__] time.
Destiny, what is Jane Doe's incentive for dragging this case
out with these memes of this long? Is it just to burn your reputation?
Dude, these guys are I mean, his cult is so [__]
stupid.
Like they just don't understand like that there is a wronged
party here. And of course the wronged party is going to uh is
going to understandably
follow through. According to Pixie's new legal filing, it has
been definite definitively determined that Destiny was material
to a minor and was in possession of of that same minor.
I'm just going to say it was definitively determined before this,
This is just a way for everybody to like get get behind it and
put it out there in a like in a way that you can't go, "Oh, well,
that's just from Kiwi Farms." That's why Destiny's so desperately
trying to tie this all back to Kiwi Farms again. Yeah, exactly,
Tequila Sunset. That's why listen, you should like my tweets,
okay? Like my tweets, retweet my tweets, and you won't look All
right?
They put it on the record. It's been made a matter of public
record. There you go. There you go. Everyone can safely say it
now. Yes, exactly.
Lock him up. I mean, yeah, that's um
What is this in in Pixie's
opposition to Destiny's motion to dismiss her legal team reveals
that Rose, the then underage child Destiny was exchanging with,
has been issued a subpoena and is sent to be deposed.
After finally ascertaining Rose's legal identity, plaintiff has
Hold on. Okay, to be fair, the expert basically just ripped Kiwi
Farms images and talking points we found out, but lmao. No no
no no no. You You need to
those points are valid on their own regardless of where they
come from. And it's very possible that legal ex that that that
tech expert didn't even look at the Kiwi Farms thread, okay?
Now, do I think that's true? But no, I don't think that's true.
But the the tech expert or the expert they hired could easily
have come to those same determinations on their own. That's just
facts based on based on the evidence provided in the lawsuit.
Those are all just facts,
But he has to try to say, "Oh, no, these facts are invalid because
they come from Kiwi Farms." That's what he's trying to do. That's
the pattern we're pointing out. We're not saying that, "Oh, none
of this stuff was pointed out in Kiwi Farms, right?" A case dismissed
due to plagiarism.
It's not that they It's not that this is like um It's not like
they don't look at Kiwi Farms. It's just Kiwi Farms happens to
be the the people who are looking at like all of his legal case
stuff with the most like most time spent, right?
So, they'll they'll see stuff. They'll be aware of [__]
And They're just like researchers for Pixie's case. But it's
very funny that Destiny turned them into that, okay? Like let's
not forget that he's the person who provided all of the docs
info that they needed to find out who Rose was and lead Pixie
to her, okay? I love that Pixie hired a private investigator,
apparently, to find the person that was like named and and geographically
figured out where they were, right? It's like, oh, the private
investigator All the actual investigative work was done for them.
Hilarious follow up to the judge asking why Rose wasn't subpoenaed
already. Yes. Also, yes. Like
Like the judge doing that and then them filing the motion to
dismiss, of course that's going to come back into the legal case,
right? When the judge literally says, "By the way, Destiny can't
say, 'Oh, this is unhinged. That person's unrelated.'" No, the
judge literally said, "Why is there no testimony from this person?"
I don't understand The judge was like, "I don't get it. Why would
there be no testimony from this person?"
You can't say they're unrelated. The actual judge is asking why
they're not
Obtained evidence that Rose's date of birth is October 30th,
2004. Thus, when Bonnell was exchanging content with Rose between
March of 2022 and until October 30th, 2022, Rose was a minor.
See Exhibit B hereto, redacted official certification of Department
of Motor Vehicles driving record.
Ah. Ah.
Yeah, I the the fact that he's like complaining about this
when uh this is an active court case
where obviously the the party that was um victimized is
going to do everything they can to put together a a coherent
case that
you know, like what do you mean Destiny Jane Doe's incentive
for dragging this
Superboy to attack my reputation and waste my money since she
has no reputation and never will. Hers doesn't matter. And since
her parents are apparently loaded, it's not her money, so she
doesn't care. Do you know why
we she wants to bring you down so bad if Hold on, Reebal Reebal.
Hello. >> donated $3.
Hey, JSTLK,
any chance you'll wish Rose a happy birthday on the
Uh probably not, but thank you for the three, Reebal Reebal.
It'll be kind of >> Feels so out of the blue. You were
friends before?
Bro, Dude, I saw that is like
I I was like this DG Gier has been in a coma, right? This DG
Gier has literally been in a coma for the past like 10
Cuz I there's just no other explanation here at all for this
for this message. It doesn't make any [__] sense
at
What? Why does she hate you? And she Can you tell me why she
dislikes you? Like I thought you guys were friends. >> What
is happening in this community? Are they that oblivious to what's
going on? Am I Like are they talking about Pixie here?
Who's suing him for what? I don't know this clown's news.
Dude, I don't even know where to Ooh, Hasan's falling for the
thing that I fall for sometimes. Sometimes I don't do a good
job of framing a story for new viewers who are unaware of everything,
okay? And Hasan is so into all of like the Destiny drama, right?
Understandably so cuz this guy's life is
he's like a demonic entity, okay? But understandably so, but
he's not actually presenting it from like for people who don't
understand. He's a he's just going from like his understanding,
which is fully informed. I uh I fall for this sometimes, too.
I feel bad I I feel I feel empathy. I feel like uh solidarity
with him right now. >> begin? Okay, Jesus Christ.
Destiny procured
child abuse material from a minor. 100% This is like now officially
in the court uh documents, okay?
And in the process of procuring child abuse material from a minor
I love that. So, I I would love to watch a reaction to this from
somebody who would defend Destiny just because I know their exact
argument. Their exact argument would be something like this.
It would be um actually um this is just put in court document.
It's an allegation, and that doesn't mean it's true. And then
do we get to ask them if you were talking to them hypothetically?
It's like, well, do you want to walk through the actual evidence
of this and see that it was true way before the court documents?
Like it is just clearly true regardless of any court documents?
And they'd be like, well, no. That came from Kiwi Farms. That
came from Kiwi cuz that's Kiwi Farms info. You can't use that.
That would be the only thing they could break down on.
That's it. He um um was he aware was he aware that she was 17?
Um I don't know why he did this, but sent that minor a bunch
of videos of him having sometimes consensual
consensually recorded
uh sex acts with other people and sometimes unconensually recorded
sex with other people. He had compiled
like this this entire library of content
that he sent to a minor that he was trying to
And then
Dude, I could just I I've seen the arguments, okay? Um Hasan,
can you tell me why it matters that she was a minor? Is that
really relevant to a case about
Does it matter that she sent the revenge to a minor? Why why
would she even be >> that minor or an associate or someone
leaked all of those videos. And then people basically were like,
what the
These are you know, these are people these are people that you
consider orbiters, like people that were members of his community
girls that were content creators within his orbit of influence,
girls that were dating other content creators who were also orbiters
of his.
they were obviously He still believes the Lonerbox thing. See?
Very frustrated with the reality when they found out that he
was just sending their tapes to random people that he was trying
to
So, one of the victims
actually sought damages and sued him for releasing the revenge
of them having sex
This is that court case. And then there were other victims that
I think uh all I feel like Hasan doesn't know his audience sometimes
cuz his audience, okay, he's got like the the socialists, all
right? He's got like all the the super empathetic like woke like
people who consider His audience broadly considers women human
beings. I wonder why he doesn't focus on like the the trust violate
like like this guy is like literally taking the people who trusted
him most, people he had like intimate uh
interactions with, and he's violated their trust in the worst
possible way. By his own words, violated their trust in the worst
possible way. Like he is a total piece of [__]
Right? Just a total piece of [__] >> also joined
in on the court case as
There was also another person that found out that she was actually
unconensually recorded while having sex
with this person.
There's a a a criminal uh charge potentially as well. There is.
And this has just been like an ongoing
Hasan sending critical support. We appreciate it from Hasan,
okay?
Hasan sends critical support to all the victims of Destiny. He
knows he knows the cases. He's very aware, okay?
What? This is
How do we ever hate this guy? How do we ever think Hasan was
bad, okay?
Look at this. How do we think this guy was bad? This humble Turkish
socialist merchant, okay? Socialism merchant? Socialism merchant.
This has been an ongoing legal battle for him in the state of
Florida.
And in the process
of this ongoing legal battle, he went in
the same law firm that actually defended Prince Andrew, but the
problem is he's so he's such a that he thinks he can like debate
lawyer his way out of this.
Also worth mentioning that the reason nobody goes after him is
because they fear his community. Yeah.
But That is explicitly true. Yes, that is I think basically everybody
I've heard who doesn't want to pursue anything, it's like, yeah,
I don't want any of that I don't want any of the harassment that
I'm going to get. In the process of all this stuff happening,
he literally he literally That's I know for a fact that's why
Melina wants nothing to do with it, right? Which I don't really
appreciate. I feel like that's sort of cowardly, but
Are you not scared? Um
Like I mean it I don't know. Not particularly.
I think it's like concerning.
It definitely makes me feel concerned if I were to like face
reveal or makes me feel some concern. It's like it's not nothing.
It's just like
I'd say if I don't feel scared, it's probably just that like
I wouldn't let this affect my life in general, not that it's
like not a problem.
Not that like the harassment, the the wishing death on people
with like that cultish audience, I think that is very concerning.
I just don't want to let it affect me, basically. >> literally
went to one of the worst communities of doxers
and egged them on flexing about how they would never find the
information of this minor.
And he even He Dude, listen to how closely he knows the talking
Listen. Listen to how much he Listen to how much he knows. >> communities
of doxers and nobody goes after him is because they fear his
community. Yeah.
But in the process of all this stuff happening, he literally
he literally went to one of the worst communities of doxers
and egged them on flexing about how they would never find the
information of this minor.
And he even revealed details about said minor. So, of course
that community of doxers found the information of said minor
and confirmed that she was a minor at the
Hasan is a massive fan of the Twitter, okay? I don't know which
account is Hasan's alt that follows me and retweets all of my
stuff, but
I know that it's there. I know that it's there. I know that I
can find it eventually, okay? I appreciate you, Hasan. Thank
you very much.
Like if you have an ongoing legal battle it's probably better
for you to shut the [__] up, you know what I mean?
Yep. Especially because
only a month ago or 2 months ago not shutting the [__]
up caused
people to go and find the identity of this person and confirm
that she was a minor when you were when you were from them.
Destiny, how much longer do you think it goes on for? No clue.
It looks like they want to try and make it survive the trial,
but I have no idea why. She has absolutely nothing.
Do you think he's going to pull out the ethical debate in court?
I don't know.
But some somewhere along the the the way
Somewhere along Wait, what? We don't have to cover this every
week.
Okay. Oh.
I know exactly I know exactly how he's going to react to that.
Revery MK.
Hold on. Hold on. Revery MK, right?
Interesting. Interesting.
Interesting. Very interesting. >> start banning
I haven't talked about this in months. What are you talking about?
Ah, is that true? I feel like he
I feel like months.
A month. A month and a half. I feel like I feel like I've covered
Hassan talking about it somewhat recently.
What? The roast stuff was only in August. I guess that is 2 months
ago,
And the only reason why I brought this up is because of chatter
because JD Vance is seemingly trying to go after
on some free speech
which I said was So everybody listen. Everybody has the same
opinion on that. I don't know if you guys have seen it. There's
like some JD Vance comment that seemed to be about him wanting
to go after a Florida two Florida influencers who had made comments
like avowing violence or something, right? And it's like, bro,
don't go after him for that. That's protected speech. Don't [__]
with that. Don't do that. But listen, there's also like seems
there's every indication there's some child porn there. You could
like look into that. You could get him for that. Come on, man.
Listen, you shouldn't go after him for the free speech thing,
but there's definitely something you could go after him for.
There's definitely something there, okay? was inappropriate and
And then someone said, "Oh, have you seen this?"
and revealed to me that there's new details in this court case.
I hate when go Uh-huh, you talk about this every week. I don't.
I hate when dumb
Hassan is like the shy snarker, okay? Hassan's the shy snarker.
He doesn't want to admit it. He doesn't want to say that he's
voting for snark, that he's willing to snark, that he snarks
in his in his free time, okay? Off stream. He's not willing to
say it, but he will all the same, okay? If you ask Hassan, "Hey,
are your are your neighbors snarkers?" He goes, "Yeah, I think
I think they're snarkers. I think they snark on people." Right?
But he is revealing that he himself is in fact a snarker. like
that.
As a matter of fact, the only reason why I have to describe the
details of this court case is because chatters were like, "I
don't know who the this person is or I don't know what the this
person has done." evidence to the reality that I don't actually
cover this [__] that much.
For understandable reasons.
There are far more consequential things happening in the world.
Why can't Hassan just have some fun, okay? Why can't he just
admit that he's having fun?
I He just refuses to admit it. But we all know he's having fun.
Come on, man.
It's about it. Okay. So this goes from from here to I think the
only other thing I had was the sick
So I'm going to grab the sick tweet with the other logs from
today, and then
I'll cover these logs, and then we are I think we're
we're just about done with this stuff until something new pops,
all right?
So let's check it out. Sick decided to tweet out the logs yesterday,
and I believe he tweets out more logs today,
Also, I
He grabbed these from my stream. I feel like he might have grabbed
these from my
This guy. This guy.
He's a big fan. He's a big big big fan cuz he he's not posting
the pollcat stuff today. Where's the pollcat stuff,
Where's that at? All right. Destiny's now having another meltdown
in DGG chat after Hassan read his tweet or this tweet on stream.
He makes up a story about a woman getting jealous of Ste of Benel's
of Steven of Destiny giving Hassan head.
Truth is, Destiny was actually jealous. Every girl he met had
a not-so-secret infatuation with Hassan.
Let's check out this these logs, okay? Uh Hassan is actually
talking about me. He's obsessed.
It's already just so
He's obsessed. He's obsessed with me.
Hassan is actually talking about me. He's obsessed.
[__] I feel bad for doing this because it's kind
of anti-LGBT, and I don't like to leak stuff like this. But the
huge drama I couldn't talk about from 6 years ago was when I
started spending more time with another girl. She wasn't comfortable
with me letting Hassan give me that sloppy turkey toppy anymore.
After that point, our relationship basically completely
So he's he's saying Hassan
was sucking him off. Apparently, that's what he That's what he's
saying.
Actually incorrect here. Sick.
And then Sick posts another page of logs, okay? That is
basically just Melina talking about how hot some dude look was
that she was like super nervous around, and that the person looked
like Hassan.
Destiny was seething at the fact that Poki and Lily are friends
with Hassan and not him.
No, come on. Come on.
Wait. Me flying around the US doing public debates despite receiving
pages of death threats while the VP pushes to prosecute me for
my speech, Hassan. Can't go to TwitchCon because it's too risky,
but immediately jumps to publicly announce him going to events
on IG so he can farm clout. LOL LMAO even.
I mean, it's just like winner POV. It's winner POV. Or it's just
totally winner POV. Like what what are you supposed to do?
What are you supposed to do? It's just winner POV.
Except that's Paris.
Oh, is it Paris?
All right.
She's is winner POV.
I I don't know like
He sees himself as such a victim. It's crazy. He's like the biggest
victim.
I don't I want to cover a lot more of this, okay? We're going
to do his logs. Whatever his other page of logs was, I think
he's got one more page of logs or something.
Is there Is there one more page of logs? Give me a second.
I'll just I'll scroll through it real quick. We'll do it. We'll
do it, and then we'll be We can say it's done,
We'll go through one more page here. We can say it's done.
Uh this is from yesterday, it looks like, okay?
So he goes into his chat yesterday.
He links a Kiwi Farms post. You see this guy's post? Yes, I saw
that. Worse than that. You see this code phrase? This Oh, sorry.
You see this phrase Code Cave
This stuff.
And then it's like this document control F that exact line. Their
expert witness is literally just copy-pasting from KF
Okay. So let's say that's true. Does that mean the things referenced
are
Are we saying the things referenced are false, or are they just
facts that somebody who you've made your mortal enemy for no
reason
for no reason you made these people on Kiwi Farms your mortal
enemies. You've like talked [__] about them constantly.
Is it just that the person you made your mortal enemy happens
to pay attention to this stuff and posted those facts before
the expert witness?
I know if I was an expert witness and I wanted to bill out the
most money for the least amount of time, I'd probably go check
that thread to see if like any people had given me like something
to work with.
Just saying.
Okay, let's keep looking. Their expert witness is copying. It's
actually Their expert witness, quote unquote, is literally just
copy-pasting from KF posts. It's actually so unhinged. I am losing
my mind.
This Is it unhinged to think that this is a problem?
I don't think so. It's all unhinged, man. So unhinged.
Yeah. Not just link, though. He literally copy-pasted word for
word from the post for his expert witness testimony. I wonder
if Destiny Do you think Destiny's going to have Andy B file a
motion? Your honor. Your honor. They actually copy-pasted it.
They actually copy-pasted this from from my Kiwi Farms page.
Your honor.
Uh I I object on grounds of plagiarism.
I object on grounds of plagiarism. They copied the things I did
wrong from a different person. It's not their testimony. Your
honor.
Uh is his point that the expert isn't an expert or that KF users
are expert worthy? His point is probably that that the expert
isn't an expert because I think he mentions more as you go up.
But
it doesn't matter because the expert could easily say, like let's
say you go to the expert. I'll I'll tell you what happened, okay?
Just obviously what
Pixie probably looked at Pixie or someone around Pixie probably
looked at the KF thread for like things that they would pick
out that were wrong and tried to see if there was anything like
they thought thought was valid there. And then they probably
asked their lawyer and or the expert, "Hey, is this something
that is a problem cuz it seems like it's a problem to me, right?
Oh, look at this this evidence right here. It seems like this
text has changed. Is that a problem?" And then the expert went,
"Yes, in my expert opinion, that's a problem."
Right? It's It's pretty obvious how this would all go. It's not
unhinged. It's not insane. It's not crazy. It's just like obviously
the normal progression of events when a case is being like litigated
like this publicly. And he was fully down. By the way, when he
before the roast stuff popped, he was fully down to go live and
try to humiliate Pixie, talk [__] about her and her
lawyers all the time. He's just like Ethan Klein. The only thing
he's mad about is that he is losing publicly. He is losing the
PR campaign right now. He is being humiliated. That's the only
thing he doesn't like. He would be totally down with all this
stuff happening. He wouldn't even give a [__] if
he had the public opinion on his side right now. He would not
care one iota.
It's so obvious.
It's so obvious not just not just based on his personality, okay?
It's also obvious based on the fact that
when he wrote the Kephals manifesto, he talked about how Kephals
used the fact that information came from Kiwi Farms to discount
uh relevant and critical um thoughts uh criticism relevant criticism,
okay? Relevant and salient to use a Vaush word criticism.
That you he should just use the genetic fallacy to point out
how dumb it is. And now he is doing that bar for bar. He's just
copied the strategy entirely.
He likes getting humiliated, right? Mm. I I think in a different
kind of way, but I I just there's some debate to be had there.
People who care to debate that kind of
Okay. So, adorable J already backed up. Yeah, this guy probably
almost certainly would have said, "Hey, did you Hey,
Hit the name.
I'm guessing it's like, "Hey, Destiny, did you Yeah, save the
post before it gets edited or deleted?" Nobody needs to edit
or delete it. It doesn't actually do anything in court. These
guys are actually on the page of like, "Guys, we've got them
now. We've proven that they use Kiwi Farms to source information.
We got them. We got It's over. We won. We proved that they used
KF to source the information. That means it's false."
But it's like literally just pointing out inconsistencies in
the documents Destiny himself filed.
Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
Superfly TNT, what did this guy say? Superfly TNT, Destiny lol
I like how they know and admit her lawyers are in the thread
and they're doing work for them basically.
Yeah, it's so insane. What a pathetic
Internet What did this guy say? Destiny, did you see pic with
all the comparison of the links is literally hosted on KF?
Uh yes, I did. Okay. The The expert could easily just validate
the things coming from KF and then I believe there's some stuff
from KF that wasn't included. So, he didn't feel like validating
some of the stuff
Uh So, this Affer guy says, "Why is every other reply on the
KF thread a [__] essay? Holy jobless." Affer, the
people who are in the thread are in all insanely mentally unwell,
lol. They're bit They're like They are bigger lolcows than half
the cows that get tracked on the site.
this is just me personally, okay? This is just me.
But I don't know if any of the people on the site or any of the
people in the thread could possibly be as big a lolcow as to
do something like posting additional PII about the minor that
you were having a sexual relationship with, okay? That is just
there's never going to be anything like that again. I'm sorry.
There's I can't think of another person who just told on themselves
this badly, who who was actually like kind of winning the public
PR battle and then just committed just kamikazed into the side
of a mountain. Like they could I don't I I don't get it. Like
I
I've never seen anything like it in my entire life.
Uh ASOS, every time I read CDN server in this guy's filing, like
he just treads like a boomer who has no idea what a CDN even
is. Uh you could have an individual node in a content delivery
network that is a server a CDN server. Yeah.
Does Is that Is that something that is like not there? You can
call it like a CDN node or a CDN
location, but like server's not even incorrect. What is he talking
Does he Why is he acting like he has any expertise here? Like
he could even determine this.
What did this person say? They say Oh, I can't see what they
said. [__]
Or what he's talking about. LMAO, is this not actually talking
about me? He's obsessed. This is the the being sucked off thing.
Um then he says, "Get deported to El Salvador. Pixie's lawyers
file motion claiming I fled the state to avoid subpoenas. My
mom hugging me goodbye in two years as I'm walked into prison
after my sentencing for bullying Trump." Sorry. After my sentencing
Oh, Jesus, that's way too much. Not that much. This much. Here
we go.
Uh at after my sentencing for early sentencing for early because
she has to get to the polls before they close so she can vote
Trump in 2028.
This guy's literally an expert in his field and DGG thinks they
know better. I
I'm sure DGG has people who know things about this, right?
I'm sure they do.
There. See more.
How far do I have to go down?
Right here.
What do you respond to on this [__]
There was something here from Destiny that was uh he responded
to this ASOS guy. I just want to see what it was. It was on the
CDN thing.
It's not right here?
Come on, man.
This ASOS guy is here all the time. God damn it.
Can't find I can't find it.
There we go. There we go.
Love the the CDN URL could be indexed by Google angle when Discord
CDN explicitly prevents indexer from searching their links. Expert
witness, by the way. Yeah, I pointed this out.
I pointed this out, but
they're just not saying explicitly that CDN URLs can be in there
from a different source, right? There's There's just no way you
can crawl There's no site map of the CDN. There's no like There's
no site map. You can't crawl it. So, you need to get the URL
indexed via another source.
All right. I think that's it for all of the logs.
What was it? I think
Kathy gave me something here. Hold on a
I'll check out this Kathy link real
What was this? Something about potentially criminal and that's
probably
potentially criminal and some [__] here earlier.
Hold on.
What is this? What is this mask going on? Jesus Christ.
Problem number two.
Destiny and Zip Zip does Destiny's not Destiny's not a forensic
expert. And we're going to go over Zip Zip. Zip Zip is some dumb
[__] on the internet sucking Destiny's dick. YO.
WOAH!
HOLY HOLY DISAVOW, OKAY? DISAVOW, DISAVOW, DISAVOW, DISAVOW.
>> OH, I totally I totally disavow language, but I agree
with the sentiment 100%. what they have to say.
That implies That implies I I think this is much more, okay?
we shouldn't look at the Zip Zip Destiny relationship as a gay
relationship, okay? It's far more like a YMS thing, okay? Like
Zip Zip can't really meaningfully consent to anything with Destiny.
He does not have the required sentience, all right? It's much
more like the YMS stuff. We can listen to him cope and keep keep
the gay people out of it, okay? He can piss and [__]
BUT ZIP ZIP'S NOT A [__] forensic expert. They can
make up whatever the [__] they want. THEY DON'T KNOW
HOW THIS WORKS. THEY DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER, OKAY? I don't care
what their answer is. Oh, this is what I was talking about that
like I think we all know that this is the case that this was
sent in April of of 2022, right? We all know that. For sure,
Zip Zip is the YMS dot. Yeah, basically. Basically in this scenario,
We all know that it was sent in April of 2022. We all know that,
but that's not the same as knowing it in a court of law and having
a jury agree on it and having a jury be convinced of it, right?
Those aren't the same things.
And that's something that Pixie's team is going to exploit.
They're going to say we should go to trial on this because it
is not definitively It is not like a settled fact yet. And I
I think the judge agreed as of last time. And now Destiny's present
presented like some doctored logs, some logs he put together
into a file he made himself, right? To say, "No, no, no, it is
this timestamp." And it's like, "I don't know. I don't know,
man.
I I don't trust you. You said you were [__] up, then
you did [__] it up. How How are we supposed to try?
Or sorry, how are we supposed to take this
But I will say, for me personally, I I've it's 100% certain that
it's um
that it's on in April. And I think all you have to do is say
like all Destiny would have had to do
and maybe he'll fix this. Oh, I have like questions I would ask
Sean. The one thing I would ask is I am curious if Destiny by
filing this stuff, like is there any problem with him filing
updated things? Because probably if you're Destiny, what you
do is you literally file an Excel sheet that is the the output
of everything with the Unix timestamp and you show the Unix timestamp
and when it is because then the date formatting doesn't matter.
Stop taking screenshots or pretty printed like a [__]
and show that the UTC timestamps are specific days. And there
is no way to [__] up the UT the UTC timestamp translation
because it is universal. It's just the universal time zone or
whatever, right?
You have UTC timestamps that put it in a certain place definitively
and you haven't presented that as evidence. He's like horrible
at making his own
you'd look at last successful date here 42 XX.
Hold on, what are you asking?
Cuz cuz this is a little bit different. IT DOESN'T MATTER.
MAYBE DESTINY DOESN'T KNOW WHAT THE [__] HE'S TALKING
ABOUT.
HM. If he HE WOULD HAVE GOTTEN AN EXPERT IF he Why are you giving
him advice? Uh cuz anybody would give him that advice. And it
literally
anybody would give him that advice and
I don't know. I don't want Listen,
I understand you guys might want Destiny to like any cost, okay?
But realistically
I want him to fight for the truth, right? Like I don't I don't
have to say oh don't submit the evidence of like this fact. I
don't have to say that. He did.
I'm just I'm just like I just I don't give a [__]
what a bunch of bums who [__] around on DGG or food
shops the
what they talk about. >> Oh yeah, chill chill chill chill.
Jesus Christ, YouTube allows How am I banned from YouTube right
now? Excuse me? This guy's going off. How the [__]
am I banned from YouTube? This guy's losing his [__]
mind.
Hey chill chill >> Like I don't give a [__]
what the DGG the Dali banging come up with. Chill chill chill
>> Go get me an expert. Go get me an expert that can say
why this is wrong. here. Chill chill I don't give a [__]
what they have to say.
It's coping and seething and I'm ending my Twitch stream. I'm
ending my Twitch stream. Like Destiny's got to explain why he
looks like it's all photoshopped.
He doesn't have an answer for that. He doesn't have an answer
for that. And I'm not trying to yell at you, Lou, but it's like
I I don't give a [__] these guys have to [__]
say. Like come on. Come on. Like
Like are you really going to listen to them and say oh they present
good points? Like I I
Okay. Well, Jesus Christ.
Yeah. [__] me. Jstock made fun of someone for being
fat and this guy is going crazy. What? I didn't make fun of any
What? I didn't make fun of anybody for being fat. What are you
talking about?
What's up, Azel? How's it going? What up? What up?
Potentially criminal was doing stuff
Uh let me see. Is he still live? Po- potentially
criminal. Is he still live right now? He is still live.
No, he is going offline or he's on a break. I'm not sure which.
Let's see here.
Cuz the the one thing I was going to ask about, okay? I've got
like two questions. Two questions that I think are good questions
that I want
Uh one,
for the precedent Pixie cited for making something available,
that precedent is for publishing to a site directly, okay? I
don't know if that precedent would really be that useful here
because I think it's quite different. I think you're answering
a very or you're asking a very different question here.
No, Jstock you're not that's not what it was. So I think you're
asking a very different question here.
Um I I don't think that precedent will hold up as something that
allows them to use that making available definition.
And I I just wonder what his opinion is on that. And then if
Destiny responds with corrected documents, does the initial inconsistency
or the fact that he didn't reveal that he had modified the documents,
does that hurt him going forward? Does that like do you lose
credibility with the judge? Do you lose like you like I don't
know. I don't know how that looks, right? If you kind of Let's
let's just handle it first. If if you could describe just totally
negative intent. Like he was trying to lie and present this is
like untampered with evidence that he produced immediately and
was like solid.
If he was lying, would that affect his case? And then if he's
not lying, it's just incompetence.
Right? Yeah, well Zanny Callie I'm making it easier question
first.
So and then if it and then so that would be one question then
if it was just incompetence, what would happen
I'd just be curious.
Apparently he covered a Zip Zip stream. Did Zip Zip go over this
stuff?
Zip Zip went over this stuff?
You think Destiny was actually trying to No, it's just incompetence,
Azel. It's just incompetence. That's what it is. It's incompetence
and but here's the thing is I don't know how required it is for
you to inform the court that you are creating something synthetic,
that you are doing something that's like a little off, a little
different. I don't know how much it's on you to do that.
Yeah, I saw he just went offline. Mad Max Mad Money Max.
I saw that he just went offline.
Okay, hold on. We got any We got We got some timestamps for the
Zip Zip stream? Is there any any clips? Hold on. I know how I
can check this, okay? I don't really want to watch I'm not going
to sit through an entire Zip Zip stream.
Zip Zip
Is it It's Zip Zip not Zip Zap, right?
It's Zip Zip.
Oh, nailed it. Nailed it. We got clips.
We don't have We don't have clips.
I thought we'd have clips. This is a old clip 3 days ago.
Old clip 3 days ago. Mad N O T, thanks for the 10 gifted. Let's
[__] go. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Let's go.
Let's go. Let's go.
Massive That's another hour on the stream right there. That's
another hour.
And I'll add I don't know 10 bucks or something as well. But
thank you very much, Matt. I appreciate it.
Okay, and then I'm looking for a timestamp to
I saw Ryle, did you post a clip? Somebody posted a clip. I might
just go grab the clip. Give me a second. Let me go find the clip
here.
Let me go find the clip. Um also resetting some [__]
All right. All right. The thread has a
I've got access to some people who
put more efficiently than the thread,
Oh, never mind.
Is it just in the thread? God damn it.
God damn it. Hold on. Let me find this clip somewhere.
I'm I'm finding the the clip real quick.
Take a look. Pixie's response to Destiny's stream.
I want to see Apparently he watched Food Shops watching me. Let's
uh let's click over to that.
I do want to see him commenting on my coverage if I can. If it's
here somewhere. Oh, there it is right at the end. Okay, based.
Let's go.
>> Oh okay, then I definitely then I definitely did not
read it. >> Okay, SO HERE'S THE
DESTINY WENT ON FOOD SHOPS STREAM. I
I see how it is.
I I see how it is.
Did Destiny I I think I already got told. Ryle already told me
that Destiny didn't say anything interesting, so
I don't know how much we need to be concerned about this.
There a Zip Zip Food Shops alliance, I would imagine. Yeah, there
obviously is, yeah.
Food Shops is the new Jstock. Please don't say that. Very gross.
Very gross. Very gross comment to be honest with you. Very weird
comment to make.
there were some really funny entertaining people there who came
on the stream from like Destiny's orbit onto my stream. It's
a way different thing, okay? The orbit for for Food Shops now
is like Zip Zip, Baby Peach
Zip Zip and Baby Peach. Okay? It's not the same thing even remotely.
I think that's evident in how often Destiny has to raid them.
Right? To prop them up?
He's got to be hard tied to them.
I'm looking for the Zip Zip >> That's the that's all the
expert witness testimony they're relying on. Besides like a background
that sounds like whatever, but it's they it's actually like it's
actually so unbelievably cringe like reading this guy's stuff.
what is it expert like there's a part in this where he's making
the argument. He keeps talking about like coriable indexed like
media on the internet. He's trying to make the argument that
Crisp, you're like you are like at least 10 times more entertaining.
You are unhinged, okay? As they would say in the DGG parlance.
You are kind of you're out there, but you're like far more entertaining
these people. Don't sell yourself short, okay? You'd never end
up on these streams. Or if you did, you'd say some very funny
things, I
Okay, here's the Zip Zip clip somebody was telling me to look
at. Give me a
What is this? What is this? 3 minutes of Zip Zip quote noticeably
absent from defense argument generally regarding 736 is testimony
from Rose that corroborate defense characterization and incorporates
into exhibit C a screenshot from Rose's Discord account.
Despite this clear directive from the court, defendant failed
to submit any corroborating evidence from Rose.
And some instead simply submitted the same evidence and arguments
that the court already rejected. So they did submit corroborating
evidence from Rose because the KF leaks were from Rose. Whether
it's from Solo Tiny leaks who's a different person from Rose
and they got a
Are the Solo Tiny leaks from things from like uh an actual export?
Like I'm thinking there's screenshots
or what I recall they were screenshots. I don't know if like
the full exported logs ever got posted. I feel like do you trust
that they're actually giving the correct
Is this what DGG watches now in offline? I have no idea. Maybe.
access to Rose's account or something. That's still evidence
from Rose because it's evidence from her Discord account. So,
that would be it.
Thus, there is no need for Yeah, I'm just saying Cybert that
like I don't know if I'd say it's from Rose if it's from a different
person who's taking screenshots selectively of the things they
want to put in there. The court to revisit this issue on spaces
alone, the court can deny the motion. This is just a argument.
I mean, I don't know why the [__] they're doing it,
but
I wonder if there's a case for defamation here that we need Wait,
why is it a argument?
That like the judge said, "Hey, why don't we have Why don't we
have testimony from Rose?" proof who owned that Discord account.
I don't know if KF Arms is a good enough
I don't Now, that would be like at the end after this all this
case is over and she very Wait, hold on. somebody ask?
I wonder if there's a case for defamation here. There they would
need proof who owned that Discord account. I don't know if KF
Arms is a good enough
Uh-huh. I wonder if there's a case for defamation here that we
need proof who owned that Discord account. I don't know if KF
Arms is a good enough
I don't know. That would be like at the end after this all this
case is over and she they try that. I'm just saying, why are
they talking about Rose? Um because they want to hurt Destiny's
reputation. They want to just spread like, "Oh, Destiny was talking
to
You literally just read them quoting the judge saying, "Why don't
we have testimony from Rose?" What? Huh?
Is this guy good?
The the they aren't saying that
the testimony from Rose is missing themselves. The judge is saying,
"Why don't we have testimony from Rose?"
Hello? Could you guys get Why is there no testimony from Rose?
That would help clear a lot of this up. a minor
The judge is actually an anti-fan. Yes. That's the worldview
these people have to have is that this judge is an actual
That's an argument at all. Like the whole point like even if
it's even if it's true, which they still didn't show actually
that it's true. Granted, it appears to be true because they submitted
in so exhibit B or exhibit C, one of them
Dude, listen to how he has to do. That was some crazy footwork
right there. That was some Barry Sanders [__] that
he just did. Do you hear that? Him trying him trying to dodge
the tackle, right? Trying to dodge the the like oh, is this proving
that Rose was A NO, NO, NO, NO, HOLD ON. HOLD ON. It's like it
appears to be true, but we don't know it to be true. Hold on.
Hold on.
That guy just went That's one of the bad Barry Sanders run, okay?
Runs. He like went 15 yards backwards. He didn't turn it around,
okay? He just got tackled 15 yards behind the line of scrimmage.
So, exhibit B, this is the quote unquote proof that uh Rose's
date of birth is October 30th, 2024 or 2004 red.
uh like DMV record or whatever doesn't list the date of birth.
I don't know why they wouldn't if they already put it in here,
I don't know why they wouldn't include it here. But okay, so
it's not actually on this, but it's all redacted. So, in in theory
it's under there under that information. So, they're claiming
she was 17 years old and 11 months. Yeah, Fancy Sloth.
the Oh. Shocking. Oh, apparently
Did did not any non-DGGers pick that up? Is Fancy shocking that
Fancy Sloth would be saying that, isn't it? That's absolutely
shocking to all of the people who hung out in DGG? Very, very
shocking that the guy who was banned for harassing women in DGG
is like, "What? She's 17 and 11
Yeah. And then Zip Zip's like, "Yeah. Yeah, that's what they're
arguing, Fancy Sloth. Yes." >> claiming she was 17 years
old and 11 months. Yeah, Fancy Sloth. So,
the disclosure happened when it in April
uh according to the evidence from the KF logs and from Destiny's
logs, but
uh according to Pixie
it happened in October, meaning they're claiming that it was
when Rose was 17 and 11 months. It's
I don't know what the [__] I mean, granted that wouldn't
Hold on. No, no, no, no. I thought the reason they included that
she was a minor was to say why there might not be testimony from
this, right?
Like why why the the defendant wouldn't have sought testimony
from this person.
That's a part of their argument is they're saying, "The reason,
hey judge, I know you asked this question. Funny Funny coincidence,
we have an answer because we had to hire a a PI to go and find
this person. Well, the reason Destiny didn't want to do that
is because he knew that she was 17."
I don't know that for the sake of like making an argument in
terms of the crime the crime doesn't have is like a an element
that the person's a minor. So, it's not it's not a part of like
the sorry, the
civil violation of civil I don't know how you refer to civil
crimes. I'm just going to say crimes.
Dude, it's uh it's goofy.
Back it up. I don't know what the [__] I mean, granted
that wouldn't necessarily change it if she's 17 and 11 months.
However, obviously it's a [__] funny
But yeah.
Oh, he's just laughing at the concept of 17 and 11 months. He's
like, "Oh, yeah, it's like still bad or whatever, but yeah, it's
a funny
I Okay.
holding hold retaining That's a very funny meme. You know who
loves that meme? The FBI. The FBI loves that meme. They laugh
at that meme every time.
Can we get Can we see if J.D. Vance J.D. Vance really likes the
the gross J.D. Vance Photoshop memes, okay? The the weird the
rare Vances. He loves that meme. I wonder if he'll love the Destiny
retaining meme given his his anger at Destiny. Can someone make
sure that J.D. Vance knows about the Destiny retaining
I think that would be a very important meme for J.D. Vance to
be appraised of.
Either way, it's irrelevant to the
to Pixie's actual case because
it doesn't have anything to do with it. The whole point is that
it it was about whether he shared it with somebody, not whether
he shared it with a minor or somebody otherwise. So, I don't
know what the [__] Like yeah, I don't even know.
He's still laughing at the Whoa. Anything else?
Um if 17 and 11 months and whoa. Um no, it Guys, ephebophilia,
please. Please. Ephebophilia.
Ephebophilia, guy. Come on, man. You have to be accurate. You
have to be
Just like when Zip Zip comes in the exhaust pipe of Pixie's car,
you have to be accurate, okay? Very important.
Kidding. Kidding. Kidding.
Okay. Well,
uh well, if Destiny's rolling out the implied consent angle,
there's no way that flies if she's a minor.
Wait, but that the implied consent angle is for Pixie, not for
Rose.
Door handle stop the slander? I I I just change it to a different
part of the car every single time, Ryle. Every single time I'll
change it to a different part of the car cuz it's always funny.
It's always funny, man. It's always
Ah, man. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool.
Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. All right.
I can't believe I was a part of DGG. Don't worry. It was People
will tell you otherwise. It was a very different place before
the the great exodus, okay? Or the great replacement.
The only difference between Matt Gaetz and Destiny is that Gaetz
was actually able to fly the minor out and Destiny
I actually don't know. I don't know the particulars of Matt Gaetz's
case. I don't know if Matt Gaetz was like aware at all of the
age. Not sure.
Required joke. Brief Zip Zip joke. Required brief Zip Zip joke.
What is this from?
It's the Oh. >> Also, there's the other thing. Yeah,
Hold on. Let me back it up.
Turn this up. a complete and utter mess right now. Like like
it's it's the other thing. Yeah, essentially. Oh, hold on. Also,
just in terms of the
J Stock talking with Destiny. New filing. Re: Destiny versus
Pixie. J Stock. Am I helping this person with their like
Am I helping them somehow?
Why Why am I in the title twice?
I literally just read the docs, man. I guess today I'm like doing
a little I'm doing a little
little bit more today, but
I just I just read the docs, man.
Yikes, yo. Unlucky, dude. Unlucky.
Bonus. Say Destiny is out, okay? This administration loves So,
who cares? They're not going to prosecute that True. Yeah.
Guys, listen. It Even if Destiny's
This administration loves Isn't that
You love You love when they start breaking out the Well, even
if he is a Guys, even if he is a
Come on.
Good stuff. Very good stuff.
Careful, this is how Hutch ended up on a food shop stream.
I happen to I happen to be grossed out by the fact that Food
shops is a former
POCD
or whatever small people I don't want to be on his stream, right?
I don't want to be on his stream.
I happen to be grossed out by it. I don't think I'm in the same
risk group as Hutch is, okay? Hutch is just looking for defenders.
That's not me.
All right. I Okay, now Now that has to be it, right? Now that's
got to be it.
Am I Am I correct? Am I incorrect?